donc est ce que vous avez fait un truc
fou vous n'ont pas beaucoup à merde
moi j'ai souvent été cocu
cette émission et
l'autre qui déballe sa frappe justement
était qu'aucune
question en fin de compte et alors j'ai
été trompée avec une star internationale
du foot 1 et avec une star
internationale de la musique mais pas
fait ou non et par fatou non maintenant
pas fac et donc et donc mais on parle
d'histoire ancienne là où oui voilà et
donc l'été je peux pas dire le nom mais
c'était un des plus grands chanteurs des
boys band quoi et plus grand des boys
band voilà il n'a pas la langue n'est
pas le nom nathan l'ip nom ne vous dit
pas le nom je peux pas dire le nom
n'attendait to be free je peux pas t'en
des découpes waddell à dire le nom vous
n'êtes pas si loin mais je peux pas en
dire plus gérer non et donc non je te
préviens williams a dit non et a quitté
pour les riches alors et marlon b g
squad elle elle m'a trompée avec lui et
j'en ai eu la preuve au matin parce que
j'ai retrouvé une trace de lui dans la
maison
c'est dans la maison c'est quoi la
trahissent et qu elle tresse alors c'est
quoi le bail ou très gras le bail c'est
que
j'ai voulu lui casser la gueule tu as
voulu normal
j'avais voulu casser la gueule à
beaucoup de gens
m'a donc oui et donc ils repartaient en
train et je les courses et jusqu'à la
gare parce que je savais précisément les
heures et je les ratés c'est un de mes
plus grands regrets parce que
franchement je l'aurais un faux pas la
violence avec des conseillers mais là
j'aimerais qu'à s'intégrer mais vous
quand même mais et donc j'ai rater mais
c'est quoi en fait et on doit retenir
quoi
c est ce qu on a fait des choses folles
quand on a été trompé mais alors c'est
faux avez vous une quinzaine d'années
jacques brune pays de meuf et où bien
fait une connerie avec une meuf vous
avez tout fait pour la rattraper oui moi
j'ai été infidèle une fois dans ma vie
[Applaudissements]
avec ma copine de l'époque oui bien sûr
et évoque ses objectifs ses deux
je lui ai fait croire que je partais à
new york un week-end pour des raisons
professionnelles alors qu en fait
j'étais dans un hôtel à 100 m pourquoi
j'ai fait croire que je parte à new york
pour des raisons professionnelles en
fait j'étais dans un anneau d'or à 100
mètres de chez moi oui vous savez j'ai
des amis qui sont graphiste donc j'ai
fait un petit footing sur son verre
offert quoi que j'étais à new york n'ont
envoyé des photos etc alger regarde je
suis là je suis là et un matin je la
croise même team atépa new york tu dis
un jour mais je suis celui-là sur site
et donc pour me faire pardonner je les
invite à new york après voilà ça va
redonner bien je te font toujours sur
coup
et
c'est ça l'histoire seydoux moi vous est
ce que quelqu'un un homme qui a fait un
truc de fou pour vous je revienne sur
rien du tout moi j'ai pas dit a dû faire
un truc moi je me suis souvent fait
avoir quand j'étais infidèle donc j'ai
plutôt des mauvais souvenirs dans ce
doux dans ce registre mais mais j'en ai
à pas mais c'est pas que de leur
fidélité peut-être voilà vous avez pas
moi j'ai le plus que j'ai fait c'est de
faire un aller-retour depuis le mexique
pourrait chercher ma femme et l'a
ramenée avec moi au mexique pour paca
voyage seul mais ça n'a rien à voir
jean-michel non j'ai déjà tout quitté
dans la nuit pour poursuivre une femme
que là pour me rattraper contenir suivre
pour me faire pardonner quoi c'est quoi
l'histoire et ben non elle habitait
paris et moi j'étais parti en vacances
dans l'est de la france dans ma famille
mes racines comme ça et s'est rendu
compte en menant dans l'est ce qu'on
vous croisez quelqu'un on a croisé
plusieurs personnes un café de d'epinal
que une des personnes du café était
beaucoup plus proches qu'elle ne le
pensait de moi pendant qu'elle est à
paris que moi je restais encore epinal
et il m'a quitté elle m'a guidé le sens
même pendant le dîner
elle habitait paris à ce moment là moi
j'avais et epinal encore est pas encore
sûr ils étaient près des phrases
pas des phrases sans qu'on comprenne
bien ce soir et trompait
jamais trompé et du coup elle a failli
s'en rendre compte à la fin du dîner
quand une personne est venue me voir
pendant le dîner est rendu compte qu'on
était très proche du coup elle a quitté
la table
jean-michel
88 voilà et du coup j'ai tout quitté je
travaillais encore à épines à ce moment
là et j'ai dû tout quitter pour la super
le faire la preuve que l'étude est
désormais
je vais encore rester finale j'avais un
travail là bas j'avais une famille
j'avais tout et j'ai dû tout quitter la
nuit pour lui prouver que c'était fini
ce genre d'histoire ne m'arriverait plus
voilà au moins par jour c'est parce que
je les ai suivis je suis j'ai tout
quitté dans la nuit pourrait suivre à
paris la retrouver à paris et lui dire
que c'était fini tout ça que ma temps je
m'installe à paris je reste avec elle et
toutes mes histoires précédentes
dégueulasse c'était fini et alors elle
s'apprend quinze jours à venir samedi
quinze jours bref ça remplit bien sûr
bas et on s'est mariés après non
belle histoire je suis désolé belle
histoire il a divorcé depuis j'y mets
alors j'ai travaillé tout j'ai tout
quitté pour travailler tous aimeraient
aller au bout de briller le refaire
[Rires]